in rogue one a Star Wars story virtually
every main character is killed during
the film's climax but in the original
version though gen Ursa and Cassie and
and/or actually survived how would the
events of the original Star Wars trilogy
have been different if these two heroes
made it out alive Jenner so was the main
protagonist of rogue one she included
elements of Luke Skywalker Princess Leia
and Han Solo all rolled into her
personality and would have fit right in
with all of them in the rebellions inner
circle if she'd survived she effectively
leads the mission to steal the Death
Star plans and shows off clever planning
skills bravery and leadership abilities
that could certainly come in handy
during the hard years that would follow
the Battle of Scarah if she'd survived
from the escape from the Death Star to
the frozen battlefields of Hoth it's
tough to imagine a battle in which gen
wouldn't be an asset you also have to
wonder if she could have found herself
as part of a love triangle with Princess
Leia and a smitten Han Solo if she had
would there have ever been a kylo Ren to
cause all that trouble in the force
awakens we meet Cassy an and/or well
into his career as a spy and from his
very first moments it's clear he handles
the uglier side of the hope-filled
rebellion
all right
[Music]
we've never really met a character like
him before in the big screen Star Wars
films so it would have been interesting
to see the contributions this kind of
pragmatist might have made in the war
rooms of the original trilogy he would
have almost certainly brought a darker
edge to the rebellion tactics and you
have to wonder what other useful Intel
he might have acquired that he survived
to keep fighting while or so and and or
were the only two heroes to survive
rogue ones original screenplay how would
the Star Wars universe have changed if
other important characters survived
Lucasfilm has been open about the fact
that saw guerreras role in rogue one was
originally planned to be a whole lot
more than what made it to the screen
after saw was first introduced in the
Clone Wars animated series Lucasfilm had
bigger plans for his team of extremist
rebels in rogue one unfortunately
reshoots and edits led much of his
planned story being left on the cutting
room floor instead guerreras time on
screen ended with a bang pretty early in
the film as he's blown up during the
Death Star's first test shot if he had
lived though you have to wonder what
influenced his guerrilla tactics and
extreme battle-scarred views might have
had on the rebellion at large
the rebels are desperate enough to seek
him out in rogue one so it stands to
reason that he could have risen to a
leadership role under the right
circumstances that might have given the
Alliance some inner turmoil from a
faction that believed blowing up the
Death Star and throwing the Emperor down
a reactor shaft weren't going far enough
and getting vengeance on their enemies
we've seen plenty of splinter factions
in the Empire including the first order
but if he'd lived
Saagar era might have been the one to
push the good guys into a much darker
place to cheer at em way and Bay's
Malthus were put out of work when the
Empire laid siege to the ancient temple
they'd been tasked with defending but
they never lost their sense of what was
worth fighting for as a result they get
roped into Jen's mission and proved to
be critically important soldiers in that
field they may not be Jedi but they
still fight for the force and in cheer
its case that dedication seems pretty
unique the force is with me and I am
with the force and I fear nothing if
these two had survived the era of the
original trilogy they could have come
find that same ground-level approach
with the renowned and respect they would
have earned with their crucial part in
taking down the Empire's super weapon
maybe instead of the altruistic may the
force be with you the rebels would have
been quoting cheer it's much more
confident mantra the forces with me
instead bode is instrumental in getting
word out that a flaw potentially exists
in the Death Star after being given his
secret mission by gens father from deep
inside the Empire as far as his place in
rogue one Bodhi serves as the team's
pilot and communications expert he also
shows some creativity in confusing the
Imperial soldiers by faking calls on the
radio to make it seem their small strike
team is more like a full-on army had
Bodie survived his outside-the-box
approach and ingenuity could have been
more than useful for the burgeoning
rebellion up until rogue one we really
didn't know anyone other than grand moff
tarkin was in charge of the Death Star
but it all started with Orson Crenna the
imperial middle manager spends the
entire film trying to prove his worth to
Tarkin Darth Vader and the rest of the
Empire only to get fragged alongside
everyone else when the Death Star gets
its shot on scare could chronic have
been able to protect his planet killer
when others failed well if he had lived
you have to think critics ruthless
ambition would have made him an even
more brutal commander of the Death Star
and his brush with death might have
given him the survival instinct the
grand moff tarkin lacked
evacuate in our moment of triumph
Galen's survival could have arguably had
the biggest butterfly effects on the
Star Wars universe at large as the man
who designed the Death Star
having him survive to join the rebels
would have done a lot more than just
give gen her father back he would have
been a game changer not only does he
know the Death Star inside and out but
he would have also brought a great
scientific mind to the rebellion and
additional knowledge on other Empire
projects and tipped the scales in the
war while a certain famous farm boy was
still bullseye womp rats at his t16 back
home on Tatooine despite the fact that
he doesn't seem to have much regard for
organic beings k2s o heroic lee
sacrifices his life to buy gen and
cassie and enough time to liberate the
Death Star plans
and he survived the film you could
absolutely imagine him hanging out and
providing some snarky comic relief
throughout the original trilogy imagine
a Star Wars universe where this hulking
combat-ready droid replaced c-3po as
r2d2 s best buddy put these two together
we could wrap up a new hope in about 45
minutes check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]